man it is insane in California they're
going for reparations in San Francisco
we've got some info here from NBC
payments of five million dollars to
every eligible black adult the
elimination of personal debt and tax
burdens guaranteed annual incomes of at
least ninety seven thousand dollars for
250 years and homes in San Francisco for
just one dollar these were some of the
more than 100 recommendations made by a
city appointed reparations committee
tasked with the thorny question of how
to atone for centuries of slavery and
systemic racism and the San Francisco
Board of Supervisors hearing the report
for the first time Tuesday voiced
enthusiastic support for the ideas
listed with some saying money should not
stop the city from doing the right thing
the draft reparation plan released in
December is unmatched Nationwide in its
specificity and breadth the committee
hasn't done an analysis of the cost of
the proposals but critics have slammed
the plan as financially and politically
impossible an estimate from Stanford
University's Hoover institution which
leans conservative has said it would
cost each non-black family in the city
at least 600 thousand dollars Peter I
know you live in another country
thousands of miles away from San
Francisco but how much will you
personally put in you'll chip in a
little something so that a young black
man in San Francisco can get ahead in
the world I assume yeah no I won't I'll
stiff him I'm afraid you know I'll I'll
just point to the Barbary slave trade
and say well hey you know millions of
what Europeans were captured and used as
slaves all across North Africa between
the 16th and 18th century so let's just
call it quits with the whole reparations
thing I mean it's it's laughable your
representatives in California must be
cooking and smoking meth because it's
absolutely crazy over there I mean I I
was looking at it before and I was
thinking if this actually goes ahead and
given that it's California it might do
the state is going to be on an ex on an
Express train to becoming America's
first failed days and I don't say that
lightly there's already a 22 billion
dollar deficit you know nuisance up the
charts
um
people are leaving in droves the taxes
are Sky High if you're going to start
forcing
non-black families to pay out six
hundred thousand dollars or whatever the
Hoover Institute suggested it's gonna
absolutely bankrupt the mistakes and
then that will in turn affect the rest
of Western Civilization it's absurd
slavery was terrible we will we all
acknowledge that we all appreciate it
was wrong it ended white people ended
slavery and you know like I said before
it was part of the Barbary slave trade
white people were also victims of
slavery so if you're going to have
reparations where do you draw the line
why do we stop at black people let's go
back to the very beginning of the supply
chain because it wasn't white people
Gathering up black people and putting
them in cages it was African kings and
it was the African Elite they were
selling their own people so if you
really want to get reparations let's go
right back to the source and get it from
them isn't it also just a
misunderstanding of human nature like
the idea that you can give people
something because of something that
didn't happen to them it maybe happened
to their ancestors Maybe and also
because they don't believe in IDs in
California how are we going to prove any
of this but the idea that you could hand
them a certain amount of money and then
psychologically they'd be like
okay we're good to go thanks won't need
anything else really appreciate it if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell